okay
thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
ah
sorry I'm late I was having lunch with
Julia Phillips and
we were talking about you well once
again it here at the here at the Oscars
just when I thought I was out they
pulled me back well we're here to have
fun tonight so let's put this all in
perspective it really doesn't matter who
wins because no matter who wins Saddam
Hussein will claim he did but I think
all of us feel that we are very thankful
that there are no Americans tonight
fighting anywhere
accepted paramount but
but what a night you know everybody
wanted to be on the Oscars this year
Madonna called me herself and she said
bill who do I have to fax to get on the
show
so she faxed me I faxed her twice and
she's here tonight ladies and gentlemen
three four five nothing nothing compares
with hosting this show you come out on
this stage and you feel like the norman
schwarzkopf of show business and it's a
thrill to look out at this great
audience of all these famous faces and
people I love to watch work and hope to
work with great actors like Al Pacino
Richard Harris Jeremy Irons who's
sitting over there nominated for
reversal of fortune the Donald Trump
story Kathy Bates who was so great in
misery sitting right over there I'm your
number one fan I am I have I actually
have the misery home game which is it's
a home hobbling kit it's a I'm referring
to that great scene when Kathy took a
sledgehammer she crippled the legs of a
writer so we couldn't leave anyhow to
finish his manuscript which is not an
original idea in Hollywood it so it's
page 8 of the Katzenberg memo
okay so I won't work there but you know
a lot of the nominated pictures have
interrelated themes now follow me on
this one will you okay
you have Goodfellas Godfather three the
movies about guys who kill people and
ghosts was about a guy who gets killed
and then there was a serious illness
group you had reversal of fortune about
a woman in a coma awakenings about a man
in a coma and Dances with Wolves
released by Orion a studio in a coma so
Wow I made it to ATM I made it all the
way through that joke but I think the
best title and perhaps confusing to some
people is Dances with Wolves now it's
the name in that film if you haven't
seen the film for the two of you who
have not seen that picture it's the name
that the Indians gave to Kevin Costner's
character when they saw him running and
romping with his pet wolf so they named
it for something that he did it's
unusual to some but we did the same
thing to my relatives and my family my
house we had eats with his hands
spits when he talks and cheats on his
taxes so I think
you know last year we didn't have we
didn't have an opening number last year
so I sort of made fun of the traditional
Oscar production number when they take
the titles of the best pictures and they
put them into one sort of part in the
word cheesy kind of medley but we had a
great opening number tonight
choreographed by Debbie Allen so
so tonight I won't be able to do my bed
medley I won't be able to sing its how
possible night for us
Oscar Oscar who will win the nominated
pictures are all right here we go are
you ready hey watch me now
so you whack some want and stop them in
to your trunk Goodfellas and go hold
this down the man is really stuck
Goodfellas Thank You wack that kids a
shoot and you shot some other guys too
and it said of feeling guilty you said
let's have a fool
I can't look
that he dances with world
or to conceive but he produced directed
and starred in this movie so if he wants
the dance would alone chances are he's
going to dance with a wall
he likes to dance with G is for that
little fool in you eight is for that
haunting thing you note if you do
os and for the nonce for Oscar Tifa
tickets banded prosperous dozin can it
win this lottery ghost made me take a
pottery ghost
it was made for me and this is the story
about a man named Corleone this man
killed everyone so now he's home alone
not a very nice guy shot Moe Breen in
the eye so tell me why his hair is seven
inches high
Godfather
let there be more and put two vol can
Godfather for when you're in a coma and
the doc gave zyou l dopa awakening
happy to be up now you're as simple as a
pup now
dang
we got
only Pricewaterhouse in say Chile get
the limo we're going home so
well as our that's it
Oh God
may I have the
you like me
thank you very much
Carla
that I've been working out thank you